you know this is carried over even to
our industry because uh in the news you
know we have the exotica Expo this
weekend and ron jeremy was told he can't
come really because of his they so many
porn stars started complaining about
harassment during the convention by him
I don't understand cuz I watched that
ron jeremy documentary they put out like
a few years ago and all these ports are
strict made our grady is well yeah
because it's the documentary yeah as a
documentary but you know that that
documentary came out like what in like
two thousand yeah we go you know I mean
the porn stars back then you know when I
start in the industry in the 90s like
you know it wasn't considered horrible
if a fellow porn star came up to you and
like squeeze your tits or something like
that but you know this generation of
girls is totally different right and
that didn't grow up with him I don't
know Ron it's like a lot of the old man
yeah he he was working he was like in
the 80s and the 90s but now he's just
like he's not an elder statesman they're
like yeah we know who he is but he's
just the [ __ ] dirty maybe that's
probably they feel I introduced Kendra
Sunderland who you guys yeah it was she
wasn't even doing porn porn yet but
she's doing the Cammie and I introduced
them at the exotica Expo said hey Ron
this is my client Kendra and he
literally pulled her tit out of her
bikini top and licked her nipple like
total stranger and I was so embarrassed
like I didn't make a complaint against
him because I didn't think anyone would
care to be honest with you but you know
that's a little I was embarrassed you
know she was college eyes to her she was
just stunned like she wasn't upset but I
could she was like huh like who's this
old man like that's how I mean you hear
that crazy here's so many of these
stories that the girls just stunned
because you know the old man who's well
respected in any industry who's well
respected who has power who's like you
know this guy that everybody loves if
they're doing something and they make it
seem like this is normal like if you
think this is weird you're weird because
this is just this is just normal you
know they can be the girls and people
things you do porn that you can't be
crass you know the set right can
and the thing is that he responded by
saying you know I've never had a
complaint from any of the fans you know
I've signed all these breasts they've
asked me and it's like no it wasn't them
it was the performers who had the
problem yeah and sometimes you gotta if
Ron just got has to go himself okay you
know what
that worked at one point and it was cool
but the business has changed in
mentality people in the business has
changed I can't do that [ __ ] anymore
yeah you can still try to get laid I
mean you can still flirt with somebody
but it's a you can't be groping nickel
yeah yeah that was pretty heavy like it
really kind of was like I was worried it
was gonna turn her off me and I said I'm
so sorry and that's a huge thing because
I would imagine that these conventions
he's a big draw he's a huge draw that's
why they always have but the conventions
now are like saying what no no you can't
come well I I really believe this this
Weinstein is she has really made people
wake up and and I'm sure they complained
for a while and they were like yeah you
know my husband I mentions an actor he
was in house of cards last season and he
got an email two weeks ago after this
story broke saying you know welcome to
season you know whatever seven or
something of house of cards please watch
this video is like this sexual
harassment sensitivity video and he had
to go eugen to say that he watched it
and get to sign something
so like the studio's trying to protect
themselves from lawsuits they go look he
said he watched it we yeah he as an
individual was responsible because we as
the studio did our part yeah yeah we're
trying to educate people and it's easy
to go yeah that's what we correct but
the bottom line if you look it's sued
yeah they're suing movie studios for
[ __ ] 20 million bucks or whatever
because like some some of the stuff they
cover up and some but they probably even
know happens and I mean that isn't that
that is where this goes right like like
so much of this is is legitimate and
real and all this Weinstein stuff is so
disgusting
but it's gonna be more and more and more
like we're and and maybe society
societal II would just change because
it's gonna get to a place where like oh
no he was looking at me creepy you know
what I mean that's gonna happen that's
gonna we're gonna live in that where
it's like you can't you can't do that
anymore